dans toute la france avec nos invités
isabelle sékaly nos présentes à
d'honneur de l'association commerciale
hyéroise et gilles casanova expert en
stratégie de communication
bonsoir à tous les lots merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france alors vous
l'avez vous y avez assisté comme nous
aujourd'hui assez à ces manifestations
dans toute la france isabelle sékaly nos
deux cent quinze mille personnes dans
toute la france aujourd'hui quel regard
vous portez justement sur sur ces
manifestations
parce que je me demande vraiment si les
gens manifestent contre le vaccin je ne
pense pas ils ont d'autres intentions
ils ont d'autres idées mais je dois dire
est que cette chose là j'ai l'impression
que c'est contre l'humanité qui sont à
30 défilé parce que si nous voulons
rester en vie si nous voulons continuer
à travailler ce mouvement des libertés
de vie y est allé au cinéma de danse
mêler de tout cela eh ben il faut passer
par le vaccin nous n'avons pas d'autre
solution sinon on va se trouver en
novembre/décembre fermé et là vous aurez
aucune liberté j'ai trop peur que
certains peut-être alors plus que est
obligé de se vacciner mais il ya
d'autres arrêtées dans la vie c'est de
vivre il vous croyez que s'ils ont le
temps on n'avait rien avec uma on en
serait là aujourd'hui lequel qu'on
aurait déjà disparu donc arrêtons g
casanova isabelle ces canaux évoqué pas
d'autre solution
est-ce que c'est aussi votre votre avis
ah je suis ravi d'entendre un grand
médecin sur votre antenne cependant moi
j'ai suivi ce qui s'est passé en corse
où le pass and i ter a été appliqué avec
deux mois d'avancé
on a laissé entrer depuis deux mois dans
cette région qui était toute dernière en
contamination dans le pays uniquement
des personnes qui avaient été testées
dans les 48 heures ou des personnes dont
le schéma vaccinal et est entièrement
terminée le résultat est que depuis
quinze jours cette région est en tête de
la contamination en france et c'est
d'ailleurs parfaitement cohérent avec ce
que l'on voit
en islande
93% de vacciner et une nouvelle vague
qui ne peut pas être dû aux 7% de non
vaccinés c'est ce qu'on voit aussi en
israël ou au royaume uni au royaume uni
117 morts 50 morts vaccinés avec un
schéma vaccinal complet en israël
60 % de non vaccinés sont malades mais
49 mais 39% de vacciner et 1% de
personnes dirigent donc on voit qu'avec
le nouveau variant
l'efficacité du vaccin selon les
autorités médicales israéliennes qui le
premier pays qui a été presque
entièrement vacciner est tombé de 90% à
39 % on comprend bien que dans ces
conditions
organiser une ségrégation complète de
toute la société sur la base des
vaccinés à qui on va laisser faire tout
ce qu'ils souhaitent c'est aboutir à la
situation corse c'est à dire une
situation dans laquelle on a une
explosion de contamination alors
évidemment pour une île où se trouve en
ce moment autour de sept à huit cent
mille personnes et où il y à 12 ou 18
lits au maximum
qui permettent la réanimation c'est un
ange un encombrement immédiat des
hôpitaux mais qui est lié à la faiblesse
de notre système hospitalier général on
va vous vous parliez à l'instant de
l'exemple corse est-ce que c'est
justement selon vous les chèques et de
la stratégie
du pass sanitaire
total échec total puisque c'est
l'endroit on peut la juger depuis deux
mois et non depuis lundi et là c'est un
échec absolu ça pose deux problèmes qui
n'ont rien de commun le premier problème
c'est le nouveau variant et les proches
invariants permet-il de penser qu'on
arrivera à une immunité de groupe à
travers la vaccination les états unis
maintenant dix noms l'islande dit non
israël dit non la grande bretagne dit
non ce sont les pays les plus vacciner
au monde donc ils nous disent on ne peut
pas tenter une stratégie d'immunité
globale par un vaccin parce que les
coronavirus mute très vite et donc il
faudrait arriver très vite à de
nouvelles versions du vaccin on peut
penser que d'ici trois semaines un mois
peut-être deux mois il y aura une
nouvelle version du vaccin qui permettra
de combattre ce nouveau variant mais on
peut penser aussi qu'ils lavent
apparaîtra un variant suivant donc en
vérité on voit bien que c'est l'immunité
acquise par les vannes 3 % de français
qui ont été infectés par le cos vide qui
est une vraie stabilité le vaccin lui il
permet d'éviter les cas les plus graves
il est donc tout à fait utile de
vacciner mais je signalerai que le pass
sanitaire tel qu'il est fait il punit
essentiellement les couches moyennes
supérieures urbaine et pas les
catégories populaires or le problème en
france c'est que le déficit de
vaccination il est dans les catégories
populaires les catégories populaires
elles vont pas au cinéma et ne prennent
pas le tgv est ne prennent pas l'avion
elles ne vont pas au restaurant donc
tout ça elle ne vont pas regarder la
faille est donc légale catégories
populaires qui ne font pas vacciner on
ne les pousse pas à la vaccination par
le pass sanitaires en revanche les
catégories moyennes supérieures des
villes on leur montre que maintenant il
faut obéir et que si on ne s'engage mais
je me permets de vous vous interrompt
pour faire aussi réagir isabelle séka
séka lino isabelle c'est calinaud tout à
l'heure on a entendu parler on a entendu
dire de la bouche de gilles casanova que
que ce pass sanitaire pouvait
s'apparenter à une ségrégation sociale
est ce que le le mot est fort selon vous
ségrégation sociale et le mans est très
fort et je m'inquiète doublement parce
que ils ne trouvent aucune solution que
de dire que tout est mauvais c'est à
dire tout ce qu'on a fait jusqu'à
maintenant ça servait à rien donc je
m'inquiète doublement si c'est vrai ce
qu'il nous dit eh ben j'ai coûté e.on ce
cas là je ne vois pas pourquoi on
continue à vacciner sarraï est ce que je
comprends donc elle n'a hélas échappe
complètement parce que on nous fait tout
on nous condamne à vivre watts ou alors
ce bac ce qu'il n'y ait composants vivre
et d'un coup on nous dit maintenant ça
sert strictement à rien de toute façon
sa vie ans même alors expliquez-moi
pourquoi parce que là je comprends
absolument pas ce que vous me racontez
ça veut dire que tout me dis nous allons
vivre avec un peu vide parce qu'on
trouvera pas de solution et donc on est
amené à être toujours confiné on dit
qu'on finira confiné non je ne suis pas
d'accord du tout avec vous je ne connais
peut-être parce qu'il faut c'est en
typique mais donnez nous des choix parce
que là ce que vous nous dites ça aucun
n'est ce pas ça veut dire où va du filet
parce qu'on est contre on n'a pas de
solution donc je veux vraiment du mal à
vous suivre parce que cela fait tout ça
pour en arriver à ce qu'il nous dit là
c'est très grave dans ce cas là c'est
sûr qu'on n'a pas besoin de passes
sanitaire au contraire mais je vous en
prie essayons d'être un peu plus
optimiste
on a fait des vagues ça serait pour
qu'ils puissent se protéger que d'être
encore d'autres certes pourquoi pas mais
nous dit pas ce que vous venez du tir
est-ce que l'ag casanova au fond la la
la la question d isabelle sékaly noah
est une question que beaucoup de
français se posent beaucoup ont suivi
les règles et aujourd'hui on dit
qu'effectivement le le vaccin ne protège
pas contre le corps d'un virus protège
contre les formes graves est ce que vous
comprenez aussi un peu ces français qui
ne qui ne savent plus où ils en sont ces
français qui doutent
je comprends que lorsqu'on vous a
expliqué que le masque ne servait à rien
puis que le masque est obligatoire que
les tests ne servait à rien puis que
l'était c'était indispensable lorsqu'on
vous a dit tant de choses et tant de
choses contradictoires
vous avez naturellement le sentiment
qu'on ne sait plus à quel saint se vouer
mais ce que je vous ai dit c'est pas que
le vaccin ne sert à rien je vous ai dit
au contraire ils protègent des formes
graves et leur les formes pas grave
c'est une grosse grippe ou une petite
grippe suivant votre âge si vous avez
moins de 40 ans et la plupart du temps
sans symptômes donc ne pensez pas par
exemple comme le dit libération ce matin
les enfants sont maintenant plus ciblé
que jamais par le corps d'un virus
certes mais il n'y a jamais eu d'enfants
morts jamais de moins de 15 ans mort par
le coronavirus pratiquement aucun n'a
été gravement atteint pratiquement aucun
n'a eu de symptômes donc quand la presse
de propagande là à ce qu'on est dans la
propagande écrit qu'ils sont plus
ciblées que jamais oui alors peut-être
qu'il y aura quelques malades c'est plus
ciblé que jamais le vaccin protège
vraiment des cas graves c'est-à-dire il
évite quand même singulièrement des
morts mais d'abord il faut regarder qui
sont nés morts la grippe espagnole les
morts en 30 ans de moyenne le
coronavirus ils ont 80 2 en moyenne et
pour 83% d'entre nous disent les
autorités ils ont au moins trois autres
raisons à leur mort la grippe espagnole
ils ont une seule raison ils ont 30 ans
donc on n'est pas devant une épidémie
mortelle 1° comparables ensuite ce que
je vous ai dit c'est il faut se vacciner
parce que cela évite les formes graves
mais cela évite de moins en moins la
contamination mais un nouveau vaccin une
nouvelle version peut être fait qui va
permettre peut le faire mais on pas dire
donnez nous de l'espoir
la science c'est la réalité le vaccin
les médicaments qu'on peut mettre en
face il faut les prendre tels qu'ils
sont jusqu'à ce que ça joue encore une
fois me permettre de vous deux vous de
vous couper il nous reste plus que
quelques secondes vraiment quelques
secondes très rapidement pour pour
conclure vous e-label ses casinos
vraiment qu'est ce que vous avez envie
de répondre à ce que est ce que gilles
casanova vient de dire vraiment très
très très rapidement mais j'ai envie de
répondre je crois davantage notre état
français qui nous racontent pas tant mon
sens que ça moi je suis pour le taquiner
je pense qu'il faut un espoir même s'il
n'est pas parfait il faut continuer à se
vacciner attenti a besoin de packtec de
les faire et de ne pas rester là à
attendre nous passe dans le pire des cas
de se dire qu'on me dit monsieur van
eckhardt ya peut-être des personnes
âgées qui sont décelés biais par
d'autres et constance mais je dois
avouer que dans mes clients j'ai aussi
des personnes 48 ans qui sont mode de
covin et qu'il n'y avait pas de problème
donc tout n'est pas parfait est ce qu'il
dit peut-être quelque part et la raison
je n'en sais rien je ne suis pas un
scientifique pour pouvoir juger lui
répondre mais moi dans l'aridité des
choses il faut avoir un espoir il me
pour moi s'était par la suite mais sans
merci mon sens où isabelle ses casinos
d'avoir été avec nous rappelle que vous
êtes président d'honneur de
l'association commerciale hyéroise et
merci à vous gilles casanova je rappelle
que vous êtes expert en stratégie de
communication merci beaucoup à tous les
veufs soir